all right when most of you hear terms
such as omnibus spending bill no doubt
your eyes glaze over I get it well I'm
gonna be spending bill is just what you
have to know a legislative scam because
it involves packaging a lot of the
federal government smaller spending
bills into one gargantuan bill then the
whole thing can be passed with only a
single vote in both the house in the
Senate that's nifty the long-gone of the
days of the so-called regular order when
appropriations were done the sensible
way department by department a lot more
transparent that way with each bill
being considered separately so under
that scenario Congress and the voters
who elected them have more opportunity
you see to strip out the waste and fund
only essential priorities makes sense
right well for years we've heard leaders
in both parties pledged to return to
regular order yet nothing ever happens
and it's back to these mind-numbing
continuing resolutions omnibus
nightmares and government shutdown
threats and the result is usually a
last-minute budget busting crammed down
well and sure enough as spring kicks off
here they go again and it's really ugly
Democrats are still in the minority
they're blaming the GOP poison pill
provisions for delaying any omnibus
bipartisan deal and mind you what
Democrats call a poison pill most
Republicans call essential for law and
order they insist on poison pills and
the rest hopefully they'll get serious
and we can get this done before the 23rd
of March the budget had to be finished
they went ahead 160 hundred and 70
poison pill amendments none of which
would ever survive a vote on their own
on the floor Democrats and Republicans
have worked together to reject many of
the poison pill writers from President
Trump I want to take a poison pill after
watching this well meanwhile
conservatives are in revolt against the
Omnibus because it's they're free of all
the old sequestration caps and big
shocker
it increases spending this idea that all
the bills come together and one big what
we call an omnibus ominous might be a
better word we're looking at a trillion
plus dollar deficit perhaps as early as
this October when the numbers come out
you know that's under a Republican
administration we need to do better
we've gotten into this bad habit of
thinking that money up here is somehow
free right it just falls from the
heavens and money is free it's not I
love well this means Republicans will
need of course Democratic votes to pass
the measure through both chambers and
this means more add-ons more giveaways
more junk funded for big donors and
other special interest groups it's a
total mess do you remember what Trump
promised he promised to cut spending to
defund boondoggles and yes to drain the
swamp we will immediately terminate
President Obama's two illegal executive
amnesty z' in which he defied federal
law and the Constitution a trump
administration will cancel all federal
funding to sanctuary cities we will end
illegal immigration keep the drugs from
pouring into our communities we're not
going to allow and we're not going to
fund as long as you have the abortion
going on at Planned Parenthood but as of
tonight
it looks like the stuff that should be
defunded by the Republican majority he
won't be touched at all Planned
Parenthood sanctuary cities Obama's
executive amnesty and this is my
favorite almost a billion dollars for a
tunnel connecting New York and New
Jersey oh it's a disguised earmark for
Chuck Schumer nice going Chuck and to of
course the most liberal states in
America benefit and that's the shortlist
well if past is prologue this Freddy
Krueger like omnibus bill will be
thousands of pages long and include over
a trill
dollars in spending maybe 1.3 trillion
and it'll pass with scant debate or
scrutiny my friends this is just sheer
madness it's time to stand on principle
without fear of a government shutdown
it's time to educate the public about
how both parties got off course and yeah
you have to compromise if necessary but
with full transparency and if possible
not on the core issues you are the
majority after all start really helping
president Trump drain the swamp don't
add to it you'll do the country good and
you just might surprise all the experts
in November and that's the angle